Gary B so my man thanks for having me
thanks for coming in um I wanted to come
because I know you have another book
coming out I did hashtag askgaryvee yes
sir and I'm a big fan
thank you I get a lot of our wisdom and
insight from you motivation as well you
know um it's a lot of things some of the
things that you say a lot of things that
you say and you talk about I already
believe and I already feel I feel like
with touring for the same cloth um but
I'll listen to you and I'm like that's
right reaffirm it reaffirms it exactly
it reduces what you kind of already know
and uh i'ma give example you give a lot
of boxing analogies in here and I'm an
ex-boxer that's my love and uh there's a
coach who was criticized for taking this
guy this boxer who's already an
elite-level boxer and another coach
criticized him says you didn't do
nothing for him he's already there
you're just cheerleading and this coach
said okay maybe he needed a cheerleader
at that moment you know I'm saying yes
and that's real that's real but do you
want to come to I want to share we have
somewhat of different audiences but it
does cross over and answer lap so you
know I wanted to give you my audience
you know what I mean and I try to give
them as much a good stuff as possible
and I just want them to know about you
then I make [ __ ] that no doubt don't see
it's a deduction for reigneth you rock I
appreciate a man yeah listen I keep my
stuff very basic you know I I think we
all deploy thesis against our executions
you were just talking before we went on
film you know the audience of people
that are working out in a great shape
and you're like great that's one part of
the equation
you know and you take the mentality and
the thesis and you deploy it against
that genre I do the same thing you know
I think that's where we probably
crossover there's a lot of people trying
to start businesses trying to start
their companies get theirs and
for me I just want to get them to think
about things at a higher plane because I
always say it's tactics versus religion
right hmm please can you explain that in
layman's break that down so they
understand I'll explain in a couple
different ways one working some tangible
for the audience right now everybody's
talking about snapchat right big believe
it at snapchats the next platform you
know it's a YouTube it's a Facebook it's
a big deal and somebody called me out on
my last askgaryvee show and said you're
not giving us the right answer and I
really went at them and I'm like cuz
you're looking for a tactic right you're
looking for me to say do 10 push-ups and
you're gonna have right post this on
Thursday at 4 o'clock with 7 letters in
it in this picture
and the problem is tactics change too
much where the market changes too much
you know I've started finally taking
care of my health and last two years the
things I did 18 months ago for my body
hmm aren't the right things for me right
now right no different than your he
might have needed a cheerleader right
now right and the reason I always talk
about tactics
I mean Jab Jab Jab right hook back to
boxing that's a that's a [ __ ]
textbook right it's pure tactics right
um but the truth is and you know this
it's getting people to understand the
religion understanding why you're doing
stuff right you know for me I'm always
reverse engineering like what do I want
to happen mm-hmm and then how do I get
there backwards and how do I provide
value right now I'll give an example
listen you know what's so interesting
this actually a great way to say this
yeah this is a phenomenal situation
right now cuz you start it with I just
want my audience to know you and bring
them good stuff how did this happen
today that was a good thing by you that
you wanted to put me on into your world
and my reverse is I'm spending the last
month my publisher and PR people are
yelling at me because they're like
you're passing a Wall Street Journal and
see you know I'm enough time to do the
journal and CNN and CBS but you're doing
these cockamamie and podcasts right
right and so it's like and so to me I
can do the math I know how many people
you have on your channel and this and
that I don't need to always do the
biggest thing right you go where you
feel is right right so I could be on the
Today Show right now and I may have
reached 7 million people but maybe 700
of them feel me right where is I can do
something like this or any other things
I've been doing that they got all upset
about and it may only reach a hundred
thousand or five hundred thousand but
four thousand may feel e or it's just
seven one two or it might be a hundred
but it feels right - all right so that's
people are not navigating their lives
with enough intuition and long-term to
me the energy of you reaching out felt
like the right thing to do I don't know
how to even explain it right and it's
now here we are today starting right
after this little we do some dab solar
love on the way out we go back but we've
started our relationship right
absolutely and I don't think people
think about the finish line enough
they're thinking about what's in it for
me right now right and they're not
thinking about seven twelve nineteen
forty four years from that right let me
speak one of these the origins of how I
got here
please okay so I got a DM from I believe
Brittany mm-hmm about you know the book
coming out except right on its ground
just to let everybody know I'm doing a
heavy Instagram thing where we used a
platform called ground signal you can
check it out where we found out people
following me now that the data showed
had good audiences and and I didn't
reach out blind I reached out to people
that already in my finger system and I
wanted to give them a free book because
they had audience right and we wanted to
start a relationship right I checked up
even if it was even if you were doing
you're blind right yep I got the message
yes I'm you know my closest friends are
in this room right now yo check this out
check this out they hit me up right so
so my guy he was like oh yeah I got that
too however really let me see same I
like yeah that's fine so I'm a respond
yep
explain Who I am because how I am I'm
like me and him need to know each other
we need to meet each other
it's a they're gonna I will end up like
and I understand exactly how listening
you're you're I know that you're a
dynamic thinker you're a smart dude I
get it I know it's like I I feel like I
really know you
yeah exactly so no why
it's the same way I felt in two seconds
it's why we picked and choose our spots
it's you can just taste your own exact I
believe in I just so much exactly I'm
with you so uh you know and my mentality
is like I have a I don't lose mentality
and that's what anything that's not just
like say a sporting event or whatever
that's just life right because life is
non-stop tests you know what I mean and
we'll always be put to the test there's
always challenges obstacles etc and I
literally don't accept any of that as a
impediment as a negative it's like good
this is gonna make me stronger I want to
learn something from this do you do you
like to lose [ __ ] no I don't even press
okay and I'm probably saying the same
thing you just like I seriously get off
I get it I get yeah yeah I [ __ ] love
it like like when we play basket we play
basket ball two times a week bunch of
people here at vaynermedia 6 a.m. tip so
you gotta really want to play right and
I'm out to midnight hustling so I gotta
get him in like 5 bird it's crazy I love
when we go for no cuz you know we shoot
for teams and I got the right team and
we're just Allenton and we're rolling
but I'd be lying if I told the world
that I don't get an extra special like
buzz when we lose the first three like I
I love the climb I'm gonna tell you why
because and this is something that a lot
of us have some people don't have it's
when you're at the bottom you have
nowhere to go but up right and if you're
not literally at the bottom if you're
not exactly if you're not literally at
the bottom figuratively you got to be
there you got to have your eyes on the
bigger guys the bigger you know that's
what I do I'm always comparing myself to
something above you yeah people doing
way better than me one of your sub crazy
hmm you see right up there the wine
business work when I won mmm when it was
like when there was nobody in the wine
business that debated anymore that I
built the best wine shop mm-hmm I was
done right yeah that's over I said [ __ ]
I'm worried about that with vaynermedia
right out and we've exploded work the
625 people we are becoming the shop
right he'll take a couple more years cuz
Madison
years old and [ __ ] and [ __ ] up but as
soon as it happens I'm scared because
I'm like [ __ ] it's gonna happen again
and I'm gonna go want to sell potatoes
or something right the potato cake I
mean this is it it's like when you say
you I can taste you we can you can taste
your own perfect example one of my
closest friends we always talk about
different scenarios all right well if
you just got this 500 million right now
would you think he's like yeah man I'll
just kick back and just hang out your
daughter and he said you wouldn't know
it I can't like there's no this is it
it's infinite possibilities you know
what I mean Anthony so and you know I
think that's a product Karen I'm curious
if this is what it's for you
I'm just driven by legacy so much more
thing I always say legacy is greater
than currency I I and that's why I'm out
there that's why I rocks filming and
that's why I'm doing this stuff no
question like I'm excited right now that
my great-great grandchild is literally
watching this right now all right I'm
long gone
I'm not for sure you know really
watching this right is out there not the
same here when I go to my children's
school you know it's just it's I'm
winning all their winning you don't I
mean and my son has a YouTube channel
now yes all right
has he he's 10 he just turned 10 so
they're seeing the spelling bees I see
him working out there sharing all of his
stuff you know and he he gets it he's
proud of his dad I'm proud of him you
know and also a legacy I love that you
said that because I was just talking up
some people about this when I first
started in the fitness industry um we
had photographers we have videographers
every every exponent and people make fun
of me like Lee will be famous for you
guys paparazzi like those same people a
year two years later hey so about that
YouTube thing you do young what do you
need anymore
so and it's that's one thing but you're
right the legacy I look at it I'm not
looking at like oh I'm doing something
better than you that you're not doing No
I'm looking at like legacy you know I
mean you know ancient Egypt ancient
Greece Rome they have these [ __ ]
statues of you know hieroglyphs this is
our modern method of them there's a
another thing that's quite interesting
we everybody who's watching right now
and listening we are the patriarchs and
the matriarchs of our family we will be
the first generation that is heavily and
I mean heavily documented mm-hmm so
forever forever
you're the beginning right of your
family sure thing and I don't know about
you pea how many pictures of your
parents or videos of your parents but
for ninety seven point nine percent of
us outside of people that had parents
that were famous mm-hmm we are the
starting point and I think that's a huge
responsibility I literally look at
everybody in this office and I'm like my
god they are the person that their
family's gonna be like that was the
chick that started it right and that's a
big deal right and that's a
responsibility greater than anybody's
ever had a deal with in the past and I
take that responsibility in a big way
right I want to set up the Vaynerchuk
name yeah in a legit way for sure no
doubt no doubt
so hashtag askgaryvee is why and what
I'll give you the real insert and I'll
give you the [ __ ] answer all right
the real real real answer is I love
public speaking' mmm I don't get any hi
greater than when I hit the stage that's
my competition or me walking onto the
ring mmm I literally treat it that way
I've recently told the truth of how I
think about the way I go onstage which
is I want to fight my audience when I
come with anger right um
and honestly I realized that when I was
doing Q&A mm-hmm in the last 15 minutes
that was the biggest fire right right
like my talk was great and I'm
entertaining good but where I really
separated myself from everybody was when
I did Q&A cuz I could really show my
skills right so 18 months ago Wendy Rock
and I started the show I went on a very
conscious effort to brand myself as the
QA guy right so that my talks going
forward once I got bigger I could just
roll on stage and go go right like
that's what I actually want to do right
so that's why okay why is there a book
it's a triple reinforcement of where I
want to take the brand right
the more politically correct
and true but secondarily true answer it
was the best book that I could write
right now and I had one more book to
write on my contract
I got a deliver right and it was the
best book that I could write right now
and I've been stunned by the early
reaction my haters and my biggest fans
are agreeing on the quality of it and
that's why I think I got something with
this right because it's a 360 view it's
about parenting and empathy and
self-awareness and work ethic and
leadership not just how to use YouTube
not just how to make money using
Facebook see and that's that's one of
the reasons why I'm a huge fan of yours
is because you it's not just I mean you
have vaynermedia right but the message
that the mess the the the spirit the
underlying spirit of your success is not
just being a social media guru or
whatever you know those times are it is
the father father father hood it is you
know the fact that you you know you know
[ __ ] this I'm getting shake you don't I
mean I'm going to show you guys when I'm
going through like all of the all of the
other things that make you the man that
you are and that's one thing I try to
convey to you know people that listen to
me and follow me you know and in the
fitness industry it's just like these
people is just just fitness
did you see this Fitness oh yeah oh yes
I can please anyone picture when you
look just like like everybody knew her
listen everybody knows you're you're
setting these pictures up right like
it's your pump day right it's perfect
[ __ ] light but no no this is the
thing Gary they don't know that and
that's the danger that's the dangerous
part of it these people are so
impression abou they don't know it
that's my valid point and I think you
know what's funny it just happened we
just both broke down the same statement
you're right mmm and I'm right in a
10-year window see what I'm trying to
tell the people that are taking the
perfect shots is you're gonna lose when
it's not authenticity because eventually
and you can get yours right see there's
a big difference between being rich and
being wealthy there's a big difference
between having a couple of all-star
seasons and being Hall of
me right right and so you're right I'm
not breaking it down well enough mm-hmm
people can get away with and I see it in
marketing all the time you can get away
with a couple of years where you were in
bank and and you may think you're clever
and tricking the market you're just
gonna lose over time absolutely
and see I look at it like this those
people and I'm I'm the guy who put the
reality and everyone's faces a lot of
people a lot of Industry people don't
like me but the people like me and
that's all I care about and one of the
industry people not like what is it when
you because we're good yeah like in I
know what you're doing you're exposing
truth right what would you say is that
one of the top two things you think I'm
just interested I'm first like that
you've exposed that people have real the
industry reactor poorly too and the
people like yeah well first of all arm
until recent times you have your
gatekeepers your big supplement
companies the promoters for shows etc
and people needed that to make money in
Pease then right and so I came through
in a different direction first of all
when I got into the fitness industry I
wasn't trying to you know I was just
doing me on YouTube right right and
people loved it and it it grew to where
it's at you know I now have a supplement
company um an apparel line I have a meal
prep company I mean it's a lot like when
people in the ground from the ground up
and when people ask you like so what do
you do and like I can't it's just a lot
you know I mean and it's all from the
ground up and it's all without these
quote-unquote gatekeepers now I'm
letting people know you don't need them
anymore sure they need you you know what
I mean they need you you've got they
need you and your audience to help sell
their product because YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram one exactly not
this company exactly and these companies
are seeing it so so now let they don't
like that so my example and I don't need
them you know no means and I know the
leverage letting people know yeah I
don't need that [ __ ] you're not an
entrepreneur as a kid did you like some
blow pops and flip chin like I was more
of a creative person interesting you
know I played piano saxophone tap-dance
a lot of people don't know that
yeah uh but but you know um I I mean I
was a monster and could say iTap I was
all just science and stuff but you know
you got snorting yeah was big though no
but all those in shape I always worked
out you know as a boxer you can't gain
weight it's impossible
every time I was stopped I was getting
like 20 pounds you know so when I got
our boxing at 12 where'd you run
Brooklyn oh right now all here yeah but
then I moved as a teenager to Arizona
via my father and and at a young age I
traveled all over the place fighting
mm-hmm so I had a lot of television I'm
36 now so who'd you come up with my
father I'm sorry in the boxing game
who'd you see you as a young kid oh I
was right under Floyd Mayweather
actually in school yeah so um you know I
should have been right there too I could
have been right there too and when I
stopped I couldn't watch boxing for like
five years because you stopped just life
just other opportunities I thought were
like better boxing is hard and when you
start when you start as a kid you kind
of get burnt out you know the man but
it's worth it but the the mentor
undertaking I had gotten lazy because I
didn't have my father over me all the
time however and you were at that age
what exactly know girls and you know
life right so you know with the school
but those principles that he instilled
in me then they're still here now every
group of friends I had I was always the
guy getting everybody to work out you
know what I mean when I was 12 I was
getting up jogging at 6:00 in the
morning you know and I just did
different things it made me there's no
boxing team in high school so I was
outsider you know a man the same man
it's funny I've been really I've been
really going it's funny like I almost
put it on a shelf I talked a lot about
and you guys that know my stuff
no I talked about working in my dad's
store when I was 14 when I don't talk
about is because of that I didn't play
sports in high school like I played
tennis for one year like I didn't I
couldn't it when I say that I worked
every I worked every weekend right like
like there was not a single Saturday
from the ton was in eighth grade on
mm-hmm that I was available right
outside the baseball card shows right
work to so I get it I was so outsider
like I on Friday would go work at the
store which meant that I didn't go to
the Friday high school parties right
right and the other thing and I'm sure
you felt this too the craziest thing
about that and I've been thinking a lot
by the way the reason I jumped on this
is I've been thinking a lot about what I
want to do with 4th to 6th graders huh
because what you probably felt and what
I definitely felt I'm projecting you
tell me if I'm right or wrong when
you're playing a different game than
everybody else and peer pressure doesn't
even have a shot on you oh yeah cuz
you're already out yeah like I was
already out like I was looking at it
right I wasn't hit it I was over here
while everybody was over here mm-hmm and
man if you're lucky enough to not feel
pretty pressure in high school you can
stay out of a lot of [ __ ] - I never
got in trouble in school I was
valedictorian yeah I mean I was though I
was though the one black kid in the
Chess Club you know I mean I'm not
saying I was just perfect angel but peer
pressure didn't exist and you talk about
self-awareness in the new book I bought
the Prix Dupree i pre-ordered and I read
the sample um and I'm all about that
I've been self-aware I've had that a
good level of consciousness as a union
is when I was young such a gift I was
aware you knew what you were getting
better yeah and and I knew what to stay
away from about watching other people
you know what I mean so when I seen
people I didn't have my first taste of
alcohol since I was in my 20s see - so
when I seen people drunk I'm like wow I
just want to be like that like it's not
cool the enemy my endgame with
socialization is like getting a girl yep
not looking like an idiot
oh mama love you so umm but yeah but but
in terms of our whole self awareness and
consciousness now going back to ah like
Fitness right please and people
misleading people to look like they're
perfect all the time I feel like this is
this is like one little analogy I look
at people like we're animals essentially
right hundred percent however what
separates us from the animal kingdom is
self awareness consciousness etc like a
dog doesn't really have self-awareness
he'll take a [ __ ] in front you know it's
not like embarrassing sure hump a pillow
is whatever so they don't have
embarrassment we we do you should right
we have a lot of us looking at certain
thing about you you're okay with lying
or misleading like that you don't mean
so what scares me the most in this
Fitness world in the supplement world
where how many of my contemporaries cuz
I can't call them friends cuz of this
one action are literally willing for a
buck to Peto product on people that is
not approved by the FDA that comes from
China they have no idea what's in it and
I asked some of my homies I'm like dude
what if in 24 months
multiple people die from this [ __ ] that
you're peddling you have no idea what's
in it you're not taking it yourself
right but you want to make Bank like
soapy shirt like like there's like if
you just want money sell anything
besides [ __ ] that people are putting in
their body and can get [ __ ] up because
you have no idea what's gonna happen
right no self-awareness no embarrassment
no no you know some [ __ ] is no project
right yep so I started my supplement
company by accident I never took
supplements all my life and then you
know I was personal training you know
like and I was a successful trainer I
had clients all day long from 5:00 in
the morning
I closed the gym so but I'm like entire
short energy and that's customer service
and I'm big on customer service you're
paying me 60 to $100.00 for an hour of
my time I need to be you know so I
didn't I try pre workouts and I didn't
like the I like the energy but it was
certain side effects I don't get I
didn't like so I started researching
writing and I don't have a background
and sure Kendall Klein general cool
right yeah so but I just you know
everything's on Google up yeah
researching so after work every night
I'm researching all these parties are
ingredients and I found out why I was
feeling aware I was so I I went to like
eBay and stuff like that and found labs
walking order raw materials yep so I'm
testing out stuff on myself right almost
died my first prototype
yeah because I didn't measure the
caffeine with a milligram scale I
couldn't find it you can't find
milligrams skills are hard to find
I wanna get a graph going so much yeah I
I almost went I was like in a mini coma
for like a day like I slept for
30-something hours 22 twenty-something
hours you know I mean so but luckily you
know dying I didn't die thank God you
know I found out that I put the
equivalent of 40 fat burners that much
caffeine in the tea that I drink you
don't imagine but anyway I learned what
I did it I experimented on myself
finally got a good formula right so when
you and and you know with I feel like
with any industry with the emergence of
social media when they see people
following growing and growing and
growing
you get bombarded with shortages and
short you know so my business one of my
business partners now who all was in a
supplement business was like hey you
everything about your own supplements
and I said fun of your ass I took a
picture of my kitchen and sent it to him
my kitchen like a laboratory right all
these raw ingredients a lot of [ __ ] that
didn't work [ __ ] that did work and he
was like damn with this I explained I
sent to my formula he like this is
pretty different he's interesting so uh
you know we came together and did it
I was making it just for me to take
you're gonna be this is my point ruins
flooring if you're not willing to take
yourself alright like anybody who's
watching right now you want to make a
buck
go [ __ ] garage sale and flip [ __ ] on
eBay you can make a buck like selling
people's stuff that you're not taking
yourself is it is a scary proposition
yes is they got it you they die every
day because they look in the mirror
every night knowing that they're full of
[ __ ] 100% and I when I see people rising
fast and I know I'm with you I got
friends too I wouldn't even call them
friends acquaintance people come up we
got a car got a calm acquaintances cuz
we're scared to call your friend or if
you don't believe in the [ __ ] they're
doing and then they're like you know
what I'm gonna do something it's - I'm
just like hi guys all right whatever it
makes me want to get out of the
supplement business but we formed I just
wanted a new company we told my buddies
and we're getting out of sports
nutrition period right we're doing more
optional health stuff stuff you're
finding a doctors
yawn I'm saying because I'm all about
health not just fitness and destroyers
you know I'm about being hey man it
comes down to intent right like like if
you want to break it down to its most
basic form like everybody wants to get
theirs like I'm not Mother Teresa
like I want to buy the New York Jets I
need billions lights nothing wrong with
that though especially when you don't
want to do it at anybody else's expense
I want to get there by doing good I want
to get there by giving you 51% of this
relationship it's cuz I'm so good that I
know what to do with my 49 it comes down
to talent the reason people want to take
eighty ninety a hundred percent of the
relationship is they're not good enough
unless they take a hundred percent of
people's [ __ ] I'm good enough to like
get mine on forty nine percent of the
relationship so why do you think of
course people like me I'm giving them
more than I'm asking for in return this
is why I love you so like I said I'll
hear something you say that reaffirms
something that I'm doing you just did it
uh even with what Mars is my brother
right here but we were forming uh
putting a deal together for the
documentary we're doing and we came with
the percentages and he said well he was
cool with I said here's an extra five
doctor always I love him he's [ __ ]
super talented and I'm not worried about
the money like that you know I mean I'm
doing all right like we're doing
projects everything that I'm doing Gary
it's cuz I really [ __ ] want to do it
and I feel so good about that man you're
gonna feel the best about it what the
one thing that you'll never get to see
happen which is literally how I live my
life and I'm sure if you follow me
you've heard this everything I do is
predicated on my funeral I'll never get
to see it which [ __ ] sucks but I just
basically wanted what if you do see it
no then how you see it then I'm gonna
come coming back on some difference
you'd be like yeah I'm like I'm the
greatest thank you like at the end of
day if you if you really want to win I
think living your life predicated on
everybody showing up to your funeral and
you know what it becomes your life like
I'm sure you guys have met people like
it would never dawn on me to do this and
not say hello and get everybody's Nick
like I watch it another you know I see
in other places
I like who do you think you are and more
importantly when you have that big of a
North Star it's not a tactic like I
consciously understand that people take
note that I do that I'm not confused
here
I'm willing to admit that but they also
know if somebody's doing it or not doing
it right
they also and it gets better this is
where I believe the truth is undefeated
it's also better some really good with
faces I'm [ __ ] with names but my
favorite part is when I see him at the
Phoenix Airport I'm like yo that's when
people are like oh [ __ ] he really did
pay attack you know what I mean and and
that's how I think like for us like I
think the truth is undefeated
I do think over time everything gets
exposed like I see it every day people
always ask me about MLM companies I say
I don't like them they get mad at me
because I'm I'm acquaintances with many
people in that space I'm like look I
don't like it I think all it is is
people selling people like it's not for
me now I have nope Who am I I'm not God
I'm not judging anybody right I have no
interest in like everybody selling pills
that are killing people everybody that's
doing Emma hood I'm not judging you you
do you but I have no interest in making
you feel good by me saying I believe in
what you're doing cuz I learned right
exactly and see that's what I love like
nowadays if I feel like society has
become so sensitive to where I often
feel like the bad guy by speaking my
mind and being direct if you're the
short-term bad guy in the long term good
guy right oh it always a forum yeah it
comes back every time people have come I
think for I told you so mmm like this is
where I'm vain this is where I'm not
noble like one of the biggest reasons I
think of a good guy is as I get off on
told you right I love it right I mean I
live for it mm-hmm all right I did a
video talking about people like you need
to be more humble I'm like no I don't I
said look up humble the definition arm
boom you know it's literally putting
yourself in a low-rank and whatever
situation you are and I like I'm like
look I'm not saying on my [ __ ] let's
see on the back okay let's step back
here we're on your show right now
you've been plenty [ __ ] humble Europe
you're being very kind to me I like
you're putting me on like
I think I miss no testicles against and
I think I got nothing but humility to
like it depends on when people see you
like like my mom first interacting with
you now for real like aw I see massive
humility so I think that you know if you
don't want it and there's also things
like what look what just half of cam
right cam was like I'll show you a good
you know show me a good loser and I'll
show you loser
I believe in that [ __ ] right like
everybody's on cams ass nobody was on
Belichick SAS for walking off the field
and shaken nobody's hand when he lost
his Super Bowl right like you know like
there's different zones of different
time first of all I'm my worst ego
bravado when I'm on stage that's the
context I feel like I'm on fire I feel
like I want to come at it that's me
there right I'm the best and the most
humble when I'm having a meeting
one-on-one with somebody in here that
works for me that [ __ ] up and I'm
propping them up I think that when
you're living your life in the open like
almost all of us are now you know a when
you're creating this much content like
both of us are first I have empathy for
people think that we're fabricating I
don't think people know how much how
nothing how nothing I touch tea rocks
editing hmm zero right but I don't think
anybody should believe me cuz I wouldn't
believe it right like what do you mean
you're putting your right so I get it
I'm not mad at anybody right it just
comes down to the truth we'll be right
at the end right absolutely.i same thing
that I keep saying is you upload a video
private and I just man go ahead and put
it up but we don't do the go back and
forth at all because plus there's beauty
in the beauty with you and Eve are
saying with would we and I were friends
yeah we're [ __ ] we've honestly I want
to be less of the rocks friend and I'm
not joking because I don't like one of
the things I feel so is funny do you
rock and I have actually really
interesting moment the other day where
there's a lot that doesn't make film
because I'm firing people I'm having
client caught like there's stuff going
on here and there was just a rally of
like intense [ __ ] that day and I get out
of my meeting and I look at the rock and
I'm like the rock yep or think I'm
get my just do and I was I was talking
because I could just see it in his eyes
like he he's so close now now he's
really seeing everything everything and
my true everything is way better than
what I can put out all my best [ __ ] is
hidden because it's the dark [ __ ] where
I'm the biggest light but I can't put it
out because it's somebody else's dark
[ __ ] and uh and it was funny we had a
really nice moment and I was like [ __ ]
how do i Darach over time and this has
happened with him he likes me more
because he knows me even better than
anybody else and that's gonna affect the
way he edits her because he can't help
but he's a human being and I'm trying to
figure out how to get d-roc to hate me a
little bit to put out some [ __ ] that's
you know but but it's interesting isn't
it it's super interesting that way but
it's good having somebody who knows
because this this is life not right now
he knows your spirit he knows that
wasn't what the CAPTCHA say no no at the
end of the day whatever you and I put
out on video and YouTube the bottom line
is we are interacting with two men
either 625 people that work here
there's hug been 2,000 have gone through
the building they they're all talking
about me and they're telling people over
dinner add the truth is or ah the truth
is and I know that and that's how I try
to live my life you know what I mean I
want people that I fire after they're
okay with it six months later to tell
the truth right I don't mind when the
first month out I hear stuff I'm like of
course they're bitter they're mad and
they're struggling and they're concerned
and like there's only so much I can do
with severance and stuff of that nature
um but a year later went on the next
chapter I want them to start reconciling
backwards and being like that's a good
dude
and if you do that you'll always win I
totally agree Gary yeah I take so much a
good time I appreciate what yes
hash tag Gary Vee yes March 8th March
8th uh look it's the best book ever
written by human being there you go and
so you know that should be enough to get
people in sure but you know what I think
honestly I think that this is exciting
to me because you know new a little bit
got a little more sense just now if
people like you they're watching this I
think that the human aspect of being of
success is not talked about enough
people talk about the skills what's the
hack what's the system how do you get a
thousand followers on Instagram how to
get a hundred thousand followers on
Instagram because if I get a hundred
thousand then people gonna give me
product or protein world is gonna want
me to put them on right like I know the
game I get it that should a short term
and if people latched on to you and are
watching this that I think what I wrote
and look you'll tell them better and
they'll trust you more but I try to
write a blueprint for the entrepreneur
and the executive and the human that
looks more like us than the masses right
right and the beauty of this is and one
one thing with social that I'm I want to
get to the level of is you attracted a
fan who can come to you and help put
your message out in the day worth you
gonna mean cuz I'm a [ __ ] gang back
at your that's what happens when you
start providing you know Maya and that's
gonna happen to you man my iBook is like
for your books already in there yet I
mean I presume so and it's been like is
not because I'm here it's been like that
and you know 20 it's happening to you
right now there's if people are really
listening to you or there's 7 to 10 of
them right now or that are on their way
because authenticity and quality will
the cream always rises to the top it may
be confusing at first paint Manning and
Ryan Leaf we're supposed to be the as
good as each other like that [ __ ] will
always always always always rise the
time people might not like the way Floyd
rolls with his bravado but but if you're
the best you're the best the best and
and one thing that I hope that is
comforting to my spirit is I have a big
channel Google put me in the top 3% of
fitness channels right I don't like
being in a fitness box but I'll take it
whatever suits that there's other people
that's you know where I'll have a
hundred thousand on this video in a week
they'll have a half a million in a week
right and they're putting out [ __ ]
right so I have comfort and
you know the people that are tuning in
to me are salad okay also all our people
also I'm not inside of the top of it
I want the critical acclaim no ma'am I
mean I know I'm the best businessman of
all time
I've thirty thousand on YouTube yeah
like I'm not crippled by that but I
built a hundred million dollar a year
revenue business right here that's good
that's worth three huh
this company's gonna be worth a billion
dollars in a few minutes like like you
can't let and you everybody watching
don't get caught up in you know cool I'm
250 on Instagram I'm 1.2 on Twitter
30,000 on YouTube because I stayed out
of it and whatever like it like like
letting social media numbers dictate
your success is asinine when you get to
eat I know you listen now I definitely
know now I can say this without knowing
and you get that email every day every
day from like hey I saw your stuff and
it did this for me
right yeah I got an email from a woman
yesterday a couple days ago if you saw
this new rock she said she was watching
my super 8 when I was doing my live
stream thing she said she was in
Starbucks and this kid literally was
meeting with her talking about suicide
and watched it and like it flipped a
switch in his head she's like you're
saving lives now I'm not gonna take that
because I need to I'm not gonna
hyperbolized that first of all but
second of all no man you can have five
hundred thousand people watching but if
you're not doing anything of value to
those people I'm super content with my
twenty and thirty thousand because I
know every one of those people is
getting more value out of that than
99.9% of things and that's good for me
man I want to end on this for me at
least I do a lot of expose and you don't
stand there for hours taking pictures
shaking hands and the common thing when
I first started all I knew was the
workouts with yes I tell them all the
chair yeah but now the mental dues
videos don't do as big as the workout
videos right sure and I won't stop doing
them because all that people talk to me
about is the mental Jules
the mental juice this time I just slip
on the laptop and just record from their
life I have something heavy on my heart
like always some simple like I know [ __ ]
your heart I know boom all alone but
just do the right [ __ ] thing
they will never don't know you know
exactly ever that's my thing and when
people come up to me and Sarah talks me
a lot of these to me man I get [ __ ]
goose bone yeah literally I you don't
mean to miss the most me did you start
playing with anchor yet you see
promoting that yeah yeah I'm sure do
that you know why for guys like you mean
you know like you might be walking down
right now and have a thought yeah you
got them but like boom you just do it on
the phone and it's audio it's really
good for guys like us that have like
like you know like I don't sometimes I'm
just thinking a [ __ ] and I got it and
like I don't know it would be weird so
like I can move the anchor you know yeah
and yes snapchat up I just got I just
started I had snapchat when it started
of course I never use it cuz I'm on
everything yeah so but when I kept
hearing you talk about snapchat Martha
me give this gift of straw it was
already a ton of people in error waiting
room and sales across the board shut up
and it really is not like I'm really
promoting one there it just has the
attention man yeah the attention is real
snapchat it was a pleasure
real pleasure on and I really enjoyed it
thank you I'm really excited to get to
know you guys but sure for sure
as a crew thank you